utiliza la propiedad asociativa de la
multiplicación para escribir y aquí
tenemos la expresión 12 por 3 entre
paréntesis y luego eso por 10 en una
forma diferente simplifica ambas
expresiones para demostrar que tienen el
mismo resultado entonces aquí se tiene
12 por 3 entre paréntesis y luego por 10
vamos a escribirlo 12 por 3 entre
paréntesis y luego por 10 cuando se
tiene algo entre paréntesis quiere decir
haz eso primero entonces 12 por 3 es
igual a 36
y luego tenemos que multiplicar eso
todavía por 10
y aquí conocemos el truco cuando
multiplicamos un número por una potencia
de 10 solo añadimos el número de ceros
que tenga la potencia en este caso 1
entonces tendríamos 360 esto es igual a
el término propiedad asociativa de la
multiplicación otra vez puede sonar
sofisticado sin embargo lo que significa
es que nosotros podemos asociar de
distintas formas los números que estamos
multiplicando o bien poner paréntesis de
diferente forma y tendremos el mismo
resultado entonces vamos a reescribir de
este lado 12 por 3
por 10
y si lo dejáramos así sin paréntesis
sería esencialmente lo que hicimos de
este lado primero multiplicar 12 por 3 y
luego eso por 10 pero la propiedad de
asociativa de la multiplicación dice
sabes que podemos multiplicar primero 3
por 10 y luego multiplicar eso por 12 y
obtendremos lo mismo que en el lado de
la izquierda vamos a verificarlo
3 x 10 es igual a 30
y luego hay que multiplicar eso por 12
es muy sencillo hemos visto esto antes
12 por 3 es igual a 36
y luego le agregamos el 0
es igual a 360 así que no importa como
asociamos la multiplicación se puede
hacer 12 por 3 primero y luego por 10 o
bien 3 por 10 primero y luego por 12
siempre tendremos el mismo resultado